foreign
[Music]
at the end of this talk is You Walk Away
Learning something whether it's just
about an art package or you have some
new strategies in terms of approaching
some of your more technical uh Solutions
with end users or clients or what have
you
so quick introduction my name is Tanya
casharelli I got my first start with R
in 2005. I was working at Children's
Hospital informatics program analyzing
genetic data
and I've been using it ever since I love
R I started my own company based out of
Boston called TCB analytics in 2015 and
I always have to include pork chop he's
my assistant you may see him come in
here at some point
but you feel free to contact me through
any of these Avenues uh more than happy
to answer questions if we don't have
enough time either
so what is anomaly detection uh this is
just the Wikipedia definition it's
sometimes referred to as outlier
detection but I like to say it gets a
little fancier than just detecting
standard deviations above or below a
mean it's a way to identify rare items
or events I typically use it for time
series data uh Twitter actually
developed the package which I'll get
into and they use it uh to look at
tweets per second you can use it for CPU
metrics and utilization but I'll talk
about two different industry cases in
which we were able to use and had a lot
of success doing so
so the art package like I said was
developed first at Twitter and there's
some really good papers that I link at
the end of this the slides are available
I'd definitely recommend it there's some
good reading in there I won't have time
to get into all the technical details
but
I actually used a fork from Harbormaster
and he made a few modifications to the
package one of which is it returns tidy
data frames tables and he also made the
function names a little easier snake
case aliases so you can see them 80 Ts
for time series and 80 vect per vector
so this is the package it's it's been
phenomenal for us so far
now just to talk about the
implementation or the underlying
algorithm very briefly it builds Upon A
an extreme studentized deviate test just
a big word for saying it does some time
series decomposition uh and robust
statistics in the paper I mentioned
actually benchmarks these four
approaches
Quant linear seasonal decomposition with
loss and a Quant spline the one they
said actually performed the best was
piecewise median so it looked like
stable metrics typically exhibited very
little change in the median over two
week windows so it defaults to breaking
your data into two week windows and
calculating a moving median it also
accounts for intraday and weekly
seasonalities it was pretty much
performing on par with these more
expensive calculations it's four times
faster than the other ones so that's the
red line you're seeing here
we've had no performance issues and have
given it quite a bit of data and we run
it everything in real time
so I love that this track is also called
working with people because it's the
hardest thing we do our encode and math
is typically easy compared to working
with people
and that's that's what we do day to day
typically the problems when implementing
complex Technical Solutions comes down
to
Communication Breakdown it always comes
down to that between developers and end
users typically so oftentimes you'll get
a set of initial requirements and when
building data products they almost
always change or get thrown out the
window there's just so much that any end
user I don't care how much you know the
product or the data there's so many
things you'll never be able to predict
and that could happen as soon as you
start building
or an app gets into production it just
doesn't meet the end user's expectations
they may have given you a mock-up or a
wireframe but there were a whole bunch
of other edge cases that they just
didn't think of that they want to then
tackle and we see that happen a lot
and this happens because not all users
have uh the technical understanding
sometimes they have a limited
understanding of the statistical
processes and principles and then
developers may just take those user
requirements and run with them and they
disappear and come back with an end
product
um
to and lastly developers they're not
always including those users so you
don't want to disappear and then just
come back to the user with something
that they may have not uh actually
wanted so part of that art is figuring
out exactly what the user does want
compared to what they're telling you
and that's where shiny comes into play
so we've had a lot of success just
taking ideas
connecting to real data and showing the
user something tangible something that
they can interact with and what we found
is using shiny as a collaboration Aid we
see those requirements quickly change we
see the user get excited because they're
they're now touching something real and
working with something real
and they feel more engaged they feel a
sense of ownership that typically they
wouldn't have if you were just a
developer off doing your own thing and
uh disappearing for weeks or months and
then coming back to something that they
didn't necessarily feel like they were a
part of
so this is what I like to call rapid
prototyping and it enables you to
demonstrate value before doing this
full-scale implementation it enables you
to find all these different edge cases
uh and data scientists can focus on
problem solving instead of having to
play this back and forth of well what
exactly do you want you can solve a
problem quickly come back show the
client something and then keep iterating
that way
so to get into the examples this first
one I think is pretty cool it's a
Hardware manufacturer in life sciences
they essentially build the rapid blood
testing machines that in hospitals so if
you go to the hospital hopefully not uh
when you're there and you get your blood
taken this is the company creating the
devices that give you those rapid
results
they have sensors in them that relay
quantitative metrics and help diagnose
instrument failures but what this
company was doing was deploying the
hardware in the field and finding up
retroactively that there was a problem
so they would take the machine back and
analyze all of the data coming off the
machines
this seemed like a perfect opportunity
to use anomaly detection we wanted to
identify those problems before they went
out into the field
so here's what the data and
experimentation looks like we have
various metrics coming off these
machines they're things like protein
levels and analytes and they come off at
different aggregations 24 hours 12 hours
Etc
this anomaly detection function has a
bunch of parameters and we just play it
around with some of them and iterated on
things like what percentage of the data
should we capture anomalies for uh
should it be positive and negative
directions so above or below the
expected threshold the level of
significance maybe we really need to be
stringent here maybe we can you know
only go with 90 confidence versus 99
percent
and then that piecewise median period
that I mentioned
another thing we realized was there are
some outliers that are just insane and
anomaly detection would always pick up
and that's very indicative of a hardware
failure but the client already knew
about these they said well we know that
these are problematic so we actually did
some outlier removal and then ran the
anomaly detection and of course then
there were no anomalies detected the
input data very much makes a difference
on your end results
so those are all parameters we wanted to
play with and we were literally manually
analyzing all of this and it turns out
uh putting it into a shiny app and just
allowing myself and the client to play
with these different parameters we
quickly got feedback on hey this
actually looks like a good threshold to
use these are good parameters let's run
with these
from there we thought well instead of a
sort of top-down approach and exploring
all the different options let's alert
the user and exactly where to go so we
took the high significance anomalies
highlighted them and allowed the user to
then click one so I want to know more
about this one what's going on with
potassium or calcium and it would bring
you right back to that screen
pre-populate all the parameters again
just a nice little user experience thing
Time Saver and they could dig into the
details a little more
the code was pretty straightforward the
input data looks just like you'd expect
for a Time series there's a time stamp
and a measure we iterated over the
different significance values we also
defaulted to using one year of data
prior to the date range that the client
is actually interested in so if I care
about May of 2020 let's start with data
from May 1st of 2019 to get some of that
seasonality and more data is better for
this type of algorithm
but throughout the project uh they then
informed us hey we actually have these
limits that we we already know it's like
a you can consider it a prior Invasion
Map and so
upper limit lower limit is something
that they would say these are
automatically bad so we thought well
this seems like it's guiding us a little
more and we could probably integrate
this first we start with a completely
data driven approach agnostic from any
business logic uh but then we said well
maybe we can incorporate these these
limits and even giving them a simple
tool like this to explore those
different outliers was something that
they didn't have and they were really
doing this all pretty manually and by
hand
so then we combine those rules with the
anomaly detection and this is over a
course of a few months we got better and
better we were finding these parameters
so now the colors you see here the green
is just an anomaly that the algorithm
found based on the parameters we already
tweaked
the blue means it's approaching that
threshold limit
and these lines these vertical lines are
those thresholds which vary by analyte
and then the red is both so we decided
these are probably most important to
look at because there's strong signal
here not only your approaching limit but
it's the anomaly detection is saying
this is
you know trending differently based on
this piecewise median
the other thing we did was allow the
user to specify how stringent they
wanted this approaching limit to be so
here you can see it's not that close to
the line we were able to Define
thresholds like maybe they really want
it to get close and the way we did that
was based on quartiles so the closer
they were to the quartile of that range
the top quartile that was more stringent
and so on and we let them kind of open
up the lens so to speak to be looser
more stringent
this ended up being the best approach uh
for the client Just Not only was it the
algorithm but incorporating the business
logic as well
so when I jump quickly into the next
examples that we have time for questions
the other example and I should wrap up
also that they're using this on a
day-to-day basis it runs as a shiny app
they're able to it connects live to
their database and it's been used as a
tool to basically direct their
investigation and identify these
Hardware failures before the machines
get shipped out to the hospital so we
thought we think that's a really cool
application
and it's it's R and shiny um the price
tag is pretty good
so real world example again is a another
client that works in the sports and
entertainment business they actually do
market research around Sports technology
so things like in venue betting and
understanding how to engage fans in this
new technical age uh biometric sensors
on athletes you name it basically any
sports technology
and I like to call them kind of a market
research company for sports Tech
so what they have is a whole bunch of
news articles that they collect via
Feedly diff bot these are different
third-party tools and Leo is something
that's I believe part of Feedly and it
analyzes all the information for you
it's kind of like a
smart filter to bring in the information
they care about
okay so the data is thousands of sports
news articles
there's also entity tagging that this
Leo tool does at TAG sports teams
Technologies vendors meaning vendors
like Google Microsoft Nike
Technologies being anything from
blockchain to augmented reality
and so what we've thought here was they
wanted interesting news stories to be
surfaced to them
so we simply took the number of mentions
of these various entities over times you
could imagine Boston Red Sox are
mentioned 10 times a week suddenly
they're mentioned 30 let's investigate
why
so here's what the first iteration looks
like we have a date range we have they
can filter by league if they'd like
we're looking at all leaks here and we
have a list of anomalies that our
package bubbled up to the top
the Seattle Sounders here were
detected we click that and it gives us a
Time series look at that particular
anomaly
we can then click it and discover more
about what's happening
so on that date and shiny pops up this
nice little module
uh
the Seattle Sounders and Amazon work
together Amazon had acquired streaming
rights for Prime video soccer matches
and that's a huge thing that this
company would like to know about
so from there you can see how you can
rapid prototype and it might be manual
and your surface some anomalies but you
could imagine how this could be
automated into report give me the five
most interesting stories that week give
me the teams that are spiking in the
news and so on
another cool use case for them was it we
used it it doubled as a QC tool so some
certain things would be spiking that
shouldn't be for example the Ottawa
Senators they weren't doing particularly
well there there was really no reason it
wasn't like the playoffs or anything
this is an NHL team so we decided to dig
into it
and it turned out that diffbot was
tagging
Ott for the Ottawa Senators because
that's our abbreviation
but it also stands for over-the-top
streaming services
so we had identified a problem with the
tagging we alerted dipbot and we got
that all fixed you know on the on the
data itself so it can also be used as a
data QC tool not only to surface
interesting things but potentially
problematic things as we talked about
also in the first example of finding
Hardware failures
and now I'm leaving I think at least
four minutes for questions but final
thoughts
um again working with people is the
hardest thing we're lucky that uh
usually they're
people we've worked with so far
understand the problem and they're very
uh collaborative and I think being able
to show them these results piecemeal is
what builds up the confidence and their
understanding of the tool and why it
matters giving them the why or allowing
them to dig in to the why and Explore
More on their own is that sort of
self-service and and
freedom of analysis that they need to to
really feel like they're engaged so
Chinese been just incredible for that
because I remember the days where you
just had to show them static charts and
put together a PowerPoint and it's very
much like I'm just talking to you rather
than working together
so anomaly detection is a useful
data-driven tool when used appropriately
in our cases we had identified specific
needs for each scenario and tailored
them accordingly uh the first use case
was for proactively identifying Hardware
failures we learned over time that
incorporating their threshold limits
would actually give us more accurate
results rather than just relying on the
data uh and the other use case surface
interesting news stories as well as
doubled as a data QC tool
work always work closely with your end
users via that iterative process shiny
again is fantastic for this
I always say build fast and fail quickly
I'd rather show you something that you
think is terrible and you tear it apart
and getting that constructive criticism
to me is a good sign it means you're
invested it means you have ideas and it
means that we can we can improve upon it
very fast
and then don't leave out important
business logic where it can help you we
don't always have to just rely on
statistical models and assume it's going
to solve all our problems there's often
times that we can incorporate that
domain knowledge and it can really
improve our results so always be looking
for those uh pieces of logic that can
help your your automation or your math
or your your art package
and questions feel free again to contact
me here I look forward to hopefully
being there next year and uh enjoy the
rest of the conference
[Applause]
[Music]